un B d'autier est un ouvrier spécialisé
dans la fabrication de bardeau on
définit comme bardeau un petit élément
de revêtement permettant de protéger des
intempéries les toitures et les
façades très répandu dans l'Europe au
Moyen-Âge à la Réunion les bardau
habillent souvent les casse créoles
traditionnelles et aussi les monuments
historiques nous sommes dans les
hauteurs de la commune de Saint-Paul au
Guillaume Dominique Vallin est l'un des
derniers bar d'outier de Lille il est
arrivé dans ce métier un peu par hasard
bon la rue voà un petit peu au hasard
hein en 98 97 98 on a fait formation
avec la paix
guide pays donc pour Val le module a
tradition faut que présente un métier
longtemps mais tout le temps monte
descend là pas attention avant avant
fait le stage monte mais en 98 quand
présente ce module là attends ça c'est
un métier longt il fait là présente
ça comme
çaour bonjour et son on c'est lui
Jocelin Lapierre bar depuis près de 30
ans aujourd'hui il a passé la main à Dom
neveux mais depuis en 87 que m'avais
fait formation par Ch de métier avec un
vieux B deer même que voilà prendre ce
métier là mais
là transmettre ce métier là si si
possible al les bardau sont donc de
petites plaques en bois découpé en
différents formats Dominique nous
explique le processus de fabrication du
bardeau traditionnel réunionné depuis la
forêt jusqu'à la poste sur les toits ou
les façadesz nuisier bar de et bar de l
en même temps le bar deer est fabriquant
et le bar de li posur donc nous nous le
bois dans la forêt nous arrive nous
stock un petit peu ici après nous
tronçons la lit avec la trançonnaise par
bille de 30 31 cm de long donc avec la
grande
hache écar le bois après c'est avec le
fondo ou traditionnel que nous va
détache les plaquettes de 12 13 mm
d'épaissure pour finir le Bau nous va
finir le Bau avec la petite hache moi
comme on est droitier le Taillon il faut
il tombe à ma gauche parce que c'est là
va permettre le le la hache d'entrer
dans la plaquette
bordauappelle ici la tête du bordau ça
c'est la partie qui va être apparent et
ça c'est la queue du
bordau avec la modernisation et
l'automatisation des tâes
professionnelles la plupart des bardaux
sont aujourd'hui fabriqués par des
machines mais Dominique nous assure la
qualité n'est pas la même le B
traditionnel il reste quand même le
meilleur parce que le B traditionnel
nous trava dans le sens du fil donc
l'eau quand il descend il va suivre le
fil de bois il tendance à rentre dans le
bois le à la machine le nud que est que
le fil tourne il travaille droite donc
le est droite bien le la machine le fil
est coupé quoi les Bau fabriqués à la
main sont plus résistant que ce
fabriquer par des machines mais cela a
bien sûr un coup Dominique peine à vivre
de son métier mais pour lui rester dans
la tradition n'est pas seulement un
choix sentimental il fait de la qualité
et la qualité a aussi un prix
aujourd'hui on peut retrouve encore les
bar d'au qu' a été posé il en a plus de
100 ans il en a toujours C bar d'au là
qu' est là quand on est bien posé quand
il respecte bien l'architecture créole
le bar d'au il dit il d très longtemps
après moi il connait pas si encore mais
pour les jeunes sera difficile pour
pouvoir garder ce métier là et continuer
il faut que nous arrive à avoir des
marchés là-dessus les
architectes quand il faut garder le Bau
il faut garder le Bau et non pas retirer
le Bau pour mettre autre chose il faut
garder quand même notre cacher à la
Réunion